[Music]
yep that's kim kardashian and p davidson
getting into the spooky season i think
halloween is a total excuse just to
stand out and et has new details about
their halloween hangout here's what we
know
it's a different experience for sure
kim and pete were joined by kourtney
kardashian beyonce travis barker and
more friends on a night out at not scary
farm
a source tells e.t the group went on
multiple rides including one roller
coaster where kim and pete chaired a
cart by themselves and held hands on the
ride it was calming but was there
attraction on this attraction maybe not
the source tells et quote kim and p have
fun together pete is a friend of
travis's so it's a good time when they
all get together
and this group didn't go unnoticed
[Music]
even in the eerie fog park guests easily
spotted the star-studded entourage in
these tick tock videos
[Music]
back to kim and p we have to bump up
this moment from just a couple weeks ago
i'm just a little concerned that
physically uh
i can't handle you
if we go all the way
he might like break me
you know before their spin on the roller
coaster the two shared a magic carpet
ride on saturday night live where they
did a little more than hand-holding i
mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not i sure
am jasmine
[Music]
leading up to the scariest night of the
year kim's met gala look gave her fans
some costume inspiration the business
mogul paid tribute to these imitations
on her instagram story in our family
there's so many birthdays right around
halloween
kim kaitlyn
kendall my mom and then corey and dream
are on the same day so we have a lot of
reasons to dress up have fun you can
just be someone different you can do
whatever you want and just have fun with
it the kardashians have always been
about halloween and kim even shared a
memory with e.t that was both trick and
treat my birthday's near halloween so
i'd always have my birthday slash
halloween party together and i would
have this big jar of like gummy worms
and you'd have to guess how many were in
and then you get the whole jar and they
were my favorite so i would always tell
my best friend how many were in there
because i knew the number and i'd be
like i'll split it with you if i tell
you what it is
and guess the closest and she always
would no one ever caught on
you